my goal this year with the show is to
expand on even more topics we discuss as
well as the people that we're talking to
yes we absolutely hit our stride by
calling out regressive [ __ ] and by
addressing the regressives the tide is
actually turning people are finally
standing up to their insincere attacks
and realizing that liberalism is about
the rights of individuals before that of
the group so if you truly believe in
equality for women then you have to
defend their individual rights whether
it's to wear what they want drive a car
or marry who they choose regardless of
their religious or cultural background I
said there was an awakening months ago
and it's pretty undeniable right now
right that doesn't mean we can rest
though if anything it means we have to
dig in deeper and keep calling out
regressive nonsense when we see it
but as I've also said from day one I
want this show to be a place for big
ideas of all kinds over the course of
the next few weeks I'm gonna talk to
people from hugely different walks of
life conservative radio talk show host
Larry elder science writer and skeptic
Michael Shermer and former leader of the
English Defence League
Tommy Robinson just to name a few we're
gonna go big on topics ranging from the
election to science to spirituality and
more we're kicking off the year with
CNN's Don Lemon love him or hate him Don
is one of the few people in mainstream
media not afraid to say what he thinks
and he often pays for it via criticism
from both sides of the aisle not only
does he hosts his own nightly show but
he also reports on location from natural
disasters co-hosts electoral debates and
has even forged an unlikely friendship
with Glenn back along the way I know
when we see these people on TV we have a
way of thinking that they aren't even
human that they're just robots or
something but I can assure you from
personal experience that with done what
you see is what you get we can always
mock mainstream media and we absolutely
should trust me I have made plenty of
jokes at CNN's expense just check my
Twitter feed at the same time we should
acknowledge though that there are many
journalists in the mainstream media
trying to do good work while online
media has changed the way we get the
news I think one of the big lessons from
2015 is how online media could also be
full of
crap just because something isn't
mainstream doesn't mean it doesn't push
a narrative distort facts or outright
lie as 2016 begins let's all continue to
shed light on issues we care about talk
about difficult topics in an honest way
and see if we can make the conversations
in our lives a little more enlightened